[Music]
Wall Street is Las Vegas for smart
people
it's where you take your money if you
want to have the odds on your side and
like Las Vegas it's full of people who
think they have the winning system to
get even further ahead hedge funds value
investors your uncle who is sure that
they connect is the next big thing and
especially Jim Cramer they are all
trying to outsmart everyone else and
this makes sense the legend and mystique
around Wall Street is that if you're
clever enough you can be like Midas
ensuring everything you touch will
become gold and there's a clip from the
movie limitless that perfectly
encapsulates this allure of Wall Street
super intelligent guy gets on Wall
Street and from nothing makes millions
because he just sees things the others
don't he outsmarts them my new friend
Kevin Doyle showed me how you could
leverage two and a half times your cash
at the day trading fraud the why you
buying that the CEO was just indicted
but not for the big fat defense contract
he bribed his way into that still on
should be announced next week at the end
of the week my brokerage account
contained over two million dollars now
of course you have to take out the
exaggerated Hollywood elements but for
many people this is the sexy side of
Wall Street
bring me your four masses and if you're
smart will make you rich and many people
believe that story and chase its promise
but there was an idea that challenged
that narrative that radically suggested
that it may be impossible to improve
your odds beyond the average even
brilliant money managers hedge funds and
the best investors may be no better than
monkeys at picking stocks number one
rule of Wall Street nobody okay if
you're Warren Buffett or if you Jimmy
Buffett nobody knows if the stock is
gonna go up down sideways or in
circles
least of all stockbrokers but before we
get to monkeys let's first talk about
the big question the question some of
the greatest minds in the world have
spent their lives trying to answer the
one that would make you rich what will
the price of a stock be tomorrow and the
answers to this question are as numerous
as you might expect for an alchemy
recipe there is fundamental analysis
technical analysis buy and hold value
investing growth investing it can go on
pretty much forever and the point is
at this time it was thought that if you
had money you needed to find a genius on
Wall Street to invest that money for you
someone who through some secret strategy
managed your wealth in exchange for a
fee the idea was that their expertise
would get you returns and your money
that would more than pay for their
secret formula and this is how you made
the big bucks if you're on Wall Street
managing people's money and charging a
fee for it and amidst these competing
views of the stock market and wealthy
wealth managers along comes an American
economist Burton Malkiel who looks at
the market and essentially throws a
monkey wrench at the traditional
theories in his book a random walk down
Wall Street he says no you're all wrong
the stock market can't be consistently
predicted by any theory the only
predictable thing we have about the
market is that the whole thing tends to
increase over time no one is able to
consistently pick winners over anyone
else and boldest of all he predicted a
blindfolded monkey throwing darts at
newspapers financial pages could select
a portfolio that would do just as well
as one carefully selected by experts if
this is true Mauao goes on to say
instead of paying big bucks to Wall
Street to let experts manage your wealth
the best thing to do is to find a
minimum fee fund that buys up hundreds
of stocks without discrimination for
winners and losers and just holds them
passively because the future of a stock
is fundamentally unknowable anyways
because if your average return is the
same for both strategies expert
management and monkey management why
would anyone pay for the experts enter
the index fund of the early 70s exactly
the kind of low fee fund that now Gail
proposes you buy it pay a tiny
maintenance fee and it just plies and
holds hundreds of stocks now if you're
one of those expert investors an index
fund seems both silly and insulting
random stocks no technical analysis no
psychological analysis no chart analysis
this was a challenge to the very echo
space dollar age Don
and after almost 50 years of data the
results are in and it's overwhelming you
can find hundreds of studies on this
because this is one of the most
surprising and overanalyze things in
finance but here are the headlines over
the last 15 years index funds
outperformed 90% of actively managed
funds when you account for their fees
let me repeat that 90 percent not 50
percent 90 percent of the smartest
people on Wall Street made less money
than monkeys and the 10 percent while
given the averages it starts looking a
lot like luck rather than skill after
all given enough investors it's
self-evident that someone will gain
above average returns just by sheer luck
and we also have a study that even the
funds that do beat the index fund one
three five years struggle to continue
that positive performance and the number
that do continue that positive
performance year over year is about the
number that we'd expect from blind
chance just because you won 15 coin
flips in a row doesn't mean you're any
more likely to win the next one let's
talk about why the future of the stock
market can't be predicted this is a long
theorized idea called the efficient
market hypothesis and even for the
people who don't subscribe to that idea
there's another confounding problem at
work here it's a game theory problem
it's a situation where there are so many
rational actors in the system that the
market can't be reasonably predicted
because each time someone gets a winning
method of valuing stocks the next person
will find a way to incorporate that
strategy into a new strategy to beat the
first strategy in other words every one
strategy must take into account other
dominant investing strategies into their
formula for how the market will swing
but it's self referential because the
other rational actors will feasibly be
trying to incorporate your strategy into
their investing strategy and this is
kind of where it all breaks down it's an
ever-evolving game that you'll never win
it long enough to beat the market
average so while occasionally there are
exploits in the market they rarely last
for long and they almost always found by
different people even Warren Buffett who
is on the very short list of people you
might argue has consistently beaten the
stock market when asked what to invest
in doesn't bother naming his own
or any other instead he has a simple
answer that would make Malkiel smile he
recommends you go get some index funds
it turns out that predicting winners and
losers is impractical over long periods
of time there's no such thing as a
consistently winning strategy over the
long haul it's much more like gambling
where the house odds are on your side
you're gonna win some and you're gonna
lose some and you can't predict which
but if you stay around long enough
you'll win more than you lose really the
only thing you shouldn't do is pay
someone to come up with fancy models and
strategies for something that ultimately
comes it's chance just go and get some
monkeys hey thanks for watching that
video this is a huge topic so there are
things that I didn't get to automatic
tax loss harvesting Robo investors which
have brought down the cost of active
management significantly smart beta ETFs
which Malkiel himself is a fan of tons
of stuff that was a little bit outside
the scope of this video for you know
time sake but I left links below so if
you're interested in sinking your teeth
a little more into this topic you can do
so go so go check that out also we're
gonna be having a discussion on the
reddit so if you want to talk about this
a little more in detail and interact
with me go there artist to the music as
always are linked and I will see you
guys next time we got it
we got a fun one coming up next time so
keep your eye out for that should be
about a week or two out in other news
got a little bit of an announcement to
make
pretty excited about that I'll link some
pictures or something I hope you have as
wonderful of a month as I'm having and I
will see you guys next time